so
good afternoon to everybody my name is
bruno ota
i have worked at stern from 1967
2004 and
for the time being i am writing a book
on the
application of the wolfram language
to particle accelerators
and this talk
is a matter of fact a part
of a chapter which is
related to civil engineering at cern
what you have to realize is that
civil engineering is the first position
in the budget of an accelerator
it is extremely expensive
and the way you prepare it
do it is of course of
great importance that said i am not a
civil engineer
what my motivation was here
to investigate the data set
of uh of the world from language
and to apply it to
define it's as a geometry
of the largest tunnel in the world which
is
the lap lhc tunnel so why
did i call it lap lhc it was because
tunnel has been
built for two machines
the first one was an electron position
collider which was called lep
and which is now dismantled and the
second is the
the head-on collider which which is
running now
so let me go to a an outline
of the talk uh
i i shall explain you the the detail
let's say the the project itself
and i shall go to the geographic aspect
of it by describing a model of the earth
and then i shall go to the geometric
aspect which is
the the hc circle itself and then i
shall make a few comments
on the 3d representation
of that i'm
i must tell you also that i have been
introduced
to this technology by
jose martin garcia
who revealed me all the secrets
of the gps system and that was
absolutely fascinating
so what was the historical context of
that
in the 70s there was
a first set
of experiments on a machine called the
sps super proton synchrotron
that we shall talk about also in that
talk
but that machine had a
was converted rather boldly into
a proton antiproton collider
how it that was made i shall not tell
you
unless you ask me at the end of the talk
because the technology of anti-protons
is rather special
nevertheless that that worked
and the net result is that the
special particles the field particles
which are
responsible of the electroweak
interaction were discovered
there and these particles are namely
the w plus the w minus
and z0 which are in the range
of the hundred gev mass
at the same time fermilab
which is for some of you may be well
known
because it's just between the champagne
and chicago
there was a big project being prepared
which was a so-called tevatron so a 1tv
one billion electron volt accelerator
which was being converted
after the success of the pp bar at cern
formula followed the same way but having
a pp bar collision at 2 tv
so about 10 times higher
so the direct rate at cern
defined a strategy to meet
the the competitor world competition
and they decided to build
the largest ring between jura
and swiss border i'm for those of you
who are not familiar with
with the places it's first near geneva
in switzerland and geneva
is along the lake geneva and north
of it the the arc of jura mountains
and it is where most of the of the cern
lab
is located now
but we you you will see it in a while
uh and
the in that big tunnel
would be built the lap collider
that i talked to you before which is
a 200gv electron polytron collider
and later on the lhc
uh let's say the lab has finished his uh
his data handling in uh in the 90s
95 roughly and the lhc started
roughly 10 years later
it had a few it's a
very difficult machine especially
because it is super conducting
and it had a few difficulties to run but
now
it has reached a
full regime and has discovered as most
of you know
the the higgs boson
so to when you receive such an
instruction from the
from the directorate
you have to rethink
your knowledge of the earth
because the geometry
of the of the circle
is has to follow
a realistic realistic model of the earth
so the reference
for the earth is
the uh the gravitation
and an equipotential of the gravitation
is given as an origin at the
surface of ocean and seas
of you will tell me that there are waves
tides and so and so forth but this this
is
uh average i would say
to give a stable origin to the system
next if you adopt
that sea level reference for the
gravitation when you enter the earth
the gravitation field changes with
the position and
that has been measured very precisely by
satellites
and now we have a model
of the earth which is called the geoid
however this geroid has
a very irregular shape
and if you want to make calculations
you need to fit some surface
to the grid and the fit
is is done with a
an ellipsoid and there are even several
ellipsoids
but i shall not complicate
the purpose and and just
you can imagine that there is only one
nevertheless on that ellipsoid
there is still two interpretation
because when you work on
aligning an object on the earth
let's say kind of intuition is that
the the vertical
should go to the center of the earth
this is wrong the vertical does not go
to the center of the earth because the
earth is an ellipsoid
here and it arrives
at the point which i we can see on the
on the screen with the angle phi
which describes some latitude
and you have a second system which is in
magenta
which is a cartesian system so just to
summarize
you have to work both with a geodetic
system and with a cartesian system
and all we i shall describe
now will will be kind of
of balance between the two systems
to let's say for the cartesian system it
is rather
easy to and to to see
you have the origin for the latitudes
is the equator and the origin for the
longitudes is the greenwich
meridian
and it is all that we shall use
interview
in in the next
so now
i come to the exploitation
of the database
of the of the world from language
and especially let's say that database
is really huge and it will be still more
in in the future and
you how to enter the database that is
the first question
which is not obvious to answer
you want to access the data
of a particle accelerator
and the database is can be seen
as a set of sets and a set
has a name entity
and the the elements of the entity are
the properties of the entity
so what i did here is to use
not only an entity would be for a given
particle accelerator
but when you have to choose ins
among several accelerators and there are
many
on in the years uh
it is instead of entity it is entity
list
and you can see the particle
accelerators which are
registered on the database and
one of them is the i think you can see
the marker here
is a large hadron collider
and when i click on it
you can't see it unfortunately but
there is the detail structure
detail syntax of that
yellow frame that you use here you say
the lhc is the entity
particle accelerator large iron collider
and so this is the name
that you will use forever
in in the in the following work
so what are the elements or the
properties
of the larger one collider
you you type p for properties lhc
that was defined before of properties
between
quotation marks and a capital letter for
properties
and you can see that there is an
abbreviation accelerate
the particles which are accelerated
the center of mass energy types
coordinates diameter
operation time entity classes
experiments and what i'm interested in
is the geometry properties
namely the diameter and
the geodetic properties the position
so the diameter is given here
i call it dlu
lhc of diameter and i can see that it is
8.5 kilometers which means
a full circumference of 20 a little more
than 27
kilometers 27 kilometers that will give
you
already another magnitude of the
of the of the circle you have you one
has to build
um and you can see that there is the
unit
together with that and that is
conceptually
a list of two elements the numerical
value
and the unit
so i keep only the numerical value here
and to locate the machine i
invoke the property position
which is here and
that position returns the geographic
position
of the machine or let's say an
approximation of that position
we shall see that it is it has to be
refined
and that position which is
46 degree latitude and 6 degree
longitude can be
represented on a kind of
map a classical map
or roadmap if you like and on that map
you can recognize the
lake of genie the lake geneva in europe
not in the u.s with geneva
just at the tip here on the at the south
and as i told you at the very beginning
the sun laboratory
extends from a part of the swiss
side towards jura which is here
and that region here
takes the name of a small city which is
called jacques
and the this area is called the paid
objects in french
or the country objects or the jegs
country
but we even the foreigners say pedo legs
and fernie voltaire which is another
city we have to we shall have to
consider in a while is here
and this is the location
i would say of the center of gravity of
the
first site of cern and
this center of gravity is located in
switzerland
but you can maybe see
the kind of sawtooth which is the
borderline
so now i come to the geometry
of course you
do not decide just on a map
where you will build the machine you
have
to find information about let's say
uh political aspects of
of the region because you cannot build
such
an instrument without asking permission
to the to the villagers to the mayors
and so on and so forth
and that's a very long story
the second point is you have to take
into account the geology
and the geology
is very good
for accelerators in in the plane
where the where it is flat because it
was the ground
for a glacier and
the the rock which which was underneath
the the glacier is called moren excuse
me
no it's not [ __ ] excuse me i i forgot
pardon me i forgot the name of the rock
it will it will come back nevertheless
under on the
on the edges of the glacier there is a
moraine
and so this is a part near the jura
and that is very let's say
delicate to manipulate
excavating instruments in such a region
so
you have to take a kind of a compromise
between the various geological aspects
of the
port nevertheless assuming that all that
studies
have been made and decisions were taken
it was said that the north
side of the diameter of the circle would
be
near a village called asian way and this
is a point a
of the diameter and you can find it
with gel position which returns
the coordinates of
h and v and the point b
is near fernie voltaire that i mentioned
a while ago
which is here you can see that there are
six decimals there between five and six
so that gives you the
an idea of the precision we require
but this coordinates
constitute and longitude
and as a matter of fact you need also
the elevation so to go to the elevation
you have to go to the cartesian geometry
and take into account what we call the
genetic normal
the genetic normal is a vertical and it
points
as you saw on the first slide
not in the center of the ellipsoid and
to derive the cartesian coordinates we
use a
an instruction which is geo to cartesian
and i said here that the bottom
or let's say the surface of the machine
is 100 meter below earth level
but you see as we have on one side and
in a mountain and on the other side on
the plane
that means that the ring will not be
horizontal
that's a very first difficulty and why
is it so
because a hundred meters is considered
as a good compromise between
uh the depths of the machine
which should not radiate
to the earth level and
uh the proximity of the
of the geological plates
which makes the digging
of the tunnel affordable
knowing that you can evaluate the
distance between a and b which is
eight point four eight thousand five
hundred
uh meters but this is not exactly
the diameter the nominal diameter of the
lc
so you have to take an adjustment
which is uh called the homoseti and
in mathematics i think it's scaling
nevertheless
you do that geometrical opera and then
you redefine the point b
which was minor b at the beginning
becomes big b at this at the end and you
have the exact
position of the
the end of the diameter near the swiss
border
and you are sure that the distance
between a and b
is uh is the nominal one
now the center is midway between the two
that's
trivial
and you come now to the 3d aspects
plane axis and tilt it which is a
continuation of the
of the previous things
uh a third point yes
to define the plane the diameter is not
sufficient
you need a third point the third point
has been taken
more or less arbitrary but there is a
big experiment
in that region it's called atlas some of
you may know and we took
a point near atlas as
a third reference point
so this is the journey
the
coordinates given by your geoposition
and it is converted into
a 3d position here exactly the same as
before
and by taking a suitable
cross product we can find the
normal to the plane defines the a
b and c and the angle
between
this this axis and
and the and the horizontal gives a tilt
of the plane
which has been evaluated to uh
one one milli radian
excuse me one one degree about
so you see it's all of that to say that
at some scale you have
huge rather huge dimensions which are
measured in in kilometers and when you
came to
subtle quantities like the tilt it's
only one degree
but this only one degree is is very
important
so now
let me see
yes i want to show you
how the lhc is defined
in reality because it is not only an
abstract
circle when you want to show it you want
to see
where the experiments are located
and you want to give a really detailed
map so
to do that i measured
on the circle which goes through the
three points i've defined a b
and c
eight points which correspond to the
eight
intersecting points of the lhc
where the two beams of proto
protons collide
and the purpose is to so you have
you need a rotation operator
which in this is a relatively new
thing in a mathematical
because the geometry aspect of
mathematica has been
uh fairly developed and you have access
to
the rotation by a rotation transform
and since i have eight points to
distribute over two pi i
wrote the angle of rotation is pi over
4.
that points have to be to be
represented on the
on the on the map and
the
[Music]
the the representation is made by
markers
so
the plane which has been defined
by kind of equation cartesian equation
up to now
is converted into
geographical
representations so that's a to the thing
which
looks we saw that the tilt was one
degree
so it's almost in the plane
of the of the of the pedes here
and you can see now
i hope you can see the map
of the region with the circle in blue
and the the eight experiments
here two three four five six seven eight
in a precise precisely defined
position
and for instance it is in atlas and cds
here one and five that the higgs boson
has been
found
okay now just to finish
because time is going
i would like to show you a
genuine 3d representation of the circle
on that figure the the lhc
circle is shown in blue
the green circle
is the sps i talk at the beginning
and which is horizontal so
the blue circle is tilted by 1.6 degree
with respect to the green circle and
the sps circle is the injector of the
protons
into the lhc so how do you inject the
protons
by a in inside another tunnel
which is called the injection tunnel
and here i showed only one tunnel of
course
you have to send two beams of protons so
one goes in this direction and you have
to send another one
in the other direction so the beams can
collide
and to go from the plane
of the sps to the plane of the lhc
uh i choose to to design
a helix so you see it will be
a little like in a car park you have
several levels for the parkings
and you go from one level to the other
one by
a a ramp which which follows
a helix so it is the same idea
nevertheless here
as the two planes are not parallel a
better comparison would be for instance
for
a space for two space
orbits where
some satellite has to jump from
one orbit to the next so that would be
a i think a problem it will be treated
the same way
uh i shall stop here because i'm just
at 3 3 p.m so i'm happy to
to hear your questions
if you have some
if anybody has any questions go ahead
and put them in the passable
chat and i will read them to bruno for
him to answer
yes all right luigi says thank you for
your presentation bruno
yes
well well it was hard to understand or
a bit special oh it went well
it's okay okay yes you know more
fine so do we stop here
yes we can stop here aaron can hear the
host you can
cancel the meeting close it out for
everybody all righty
okay thank you everybody yeah thank you
for yes uh
can you tell me how i can join rejoin
the
uh stephen wolf from stock
uh yes bruno i'll email you okay
so let's just close the session yeah
perfect thank you all bye bruno